when the last year and this is a
relatively new thing the American left
has united behind a new theory of
citizenship in the United States
anybody from around the world can come
here for any reason and once they're
here they never have to leave no matter
what the original justification for
being here is and if you disagree you're
a bigot the US has a designation called
temporary protected status for
immigrants from certain countries we
have this because we're a kind country
we try to help the status is supposed to
be a short-term measure letting people
remain in the US if their country
suffers a calamity like a natural
disaster earthquake flood whatever this
program has been around for a long time
and it has been badly abused El Salvador
for example receive TPS in 2001 after a
series of earthquakes it still has it
today one third of all Salvadorans on
the globe now live in the United States
Honduran immigrants have enjoyed
temporary status since 1998 Haitians
have had it since 2010 the Trump
administration has said geez this is
supposed to be temporary let's make a
temporary and let the status of some
countries expire well in response the
left is revealing what they really think
about temporary they were actually
permanent all along with support of the
ACLU several immigrants are suing the
Trump administration saying they can't
be deported they claim that the
president has described some countries
as terrible places to live therefore
he's a bigot never mind the entire
justification for letting immigrants
come here in the first place of their
countries were terrible places to live
oh the only thing that matters is this
single principle to the left
anybody can live in the US and they
should never be forced to leave ever we
think that's the principle but to
explain it to us a healing a rule on and
done is legal director of the ACLU of
Southern California joins us right
healing thanks for coming on thanks for
having me Tucker so there's an obvious
internal contradiction here which I'm
sure you've pondered before which is the
these plaintiffs whom you're
representing are saying that it was
bigoted of the President to describe
certain countries as hellholes crappy
places to live and yet the justification
for their being here anyway and not
returning is that those countries are
exactly what President Trump said they
were so how does that work
I don't think that's quite how we see it
Tucker you know I think the the
government can create a temporary
program for
people to say 6:12 even 18 months and
but these are countries where people
have been lawfully residing here under
this u.s. program for almost 20 years in
some cases more than 20 years and all
we're saying is that when the government
that wants to change the program and
take away their status tear apart their
families their US citizen children
who've been here in high school you'd
have to have a very good reason to do
that you know and they don't have
obviously a very good reason here listen
isn't the reason itself inherent in the
program it was a temper this wasn't
permanent resettlement of people who
wanted a better standard of living what
we've done it for a lot of people but
this specific program was to say your
country is a disaster you can come here
tell it's better one third of all
Salvadorans on planet earth now live in
the United States so there's been a
massive resettlement here why is it
unfair to hold them to the standards we
agreed on in the first place
well two things Tucker you know first
it's not a question of whether or not
you can have a good reason to terminate
it is the question did the government
actually have such a reason here and so
we know that there was a bipartisan
proposal Republicans and Democrats that
proposed to the president granting
permanent residents to these people
because they've lived here so long and
he rejected that in this meeting where
he made this comment that I don't know
if I'm allowed to say this that's not
relevant actually because none of that
became law so he had a conversation with
someone it didn't go through the
Congress no executive orders were issued
so it's not really material to the the
statutes on the books now which describe
a temporary program and you're saying
that it can't be temporary because why
no it definitely can be temporary Tucker
our point is this once it's happened for
a long time rights and some of our
plaintiffs are not just immigrants right
there there's like the 14 year old high
school student born and raised in
Northern California who's studying
government who's studying the
Constitution you know who knows that the
due process clause protects persons and
not just citizens she now has to either
leave the only country that she's ever
known to go livor their parents in El
Salvador or her family has to be broken
apart there's a hundred thousand other
children you're not
you're not gonna surprise me with
stories about people suffering because a
lot of people are suffering including
millions of American citizens and I feel
sorry for all of them immigrant and
American alike that's not really the
question the question is what's the best
for the country but the question also
unresolved but you have not yet answered
is are they saying either that it was
racist to describe their home countries
as terrible places or are they saying
that their home countries are terrible
places and that why that's why they
can't go back you can't really say both
can you no no I think I think you know
the position in the lawsuit and
certainly if you look at the
designations that supports this is that
the the justifications for granting
temporary protective status to people
from El Salvador and Haiti and Sudan and
Nicaragua remain in place today the
countries could continue to be right so
Trump's comments the ones that were
reported and we don't really know
exactly what he said but I'm willing to
believe he said that because it's true
by the way a lot of these countries are
hellholes
are you taking issue with that are you
saying that it's it's wrong to call
Haiti a hellhole but no one here from
Haiti can be returned to Haiti because
it's a hellhole I mean you just engage
them that no thing right yeah no no talk
about you know that the president is
reported to have said is that the P we
don't want people from these [ __ ]
countries right and so it was a it was
an expression of animus against them
it's not the only statement I mean the
president has made many statements about
you know everybody from Haiti has AIDS
you know I don't want to go through them
all but a number of why is that
look one we just engaged with this fact
one-third of all Salvadorans in the
world live in the United States so it's
not like we have special animus towards
Salvadorans a third of their entire
population lives here it's kind of hard
to argue that we're racist against
Salvadorans isn't it no no that it's not
about the cut in fact America is not as
a whole racist against it and we have a
long history of people from from China
after Tiananmen Square from Hungary back
in the 50s and 60s after the
problems there people obviously from
Central America as well that we have
allowed welcome to this country because
of the problems that are existing in
those countries in the chrony here it's
not people want to do
exactly exactly Tekken if the government
had ended this program as they did for
example with the Ebola with the Ebola
the way you just perfectly crystallized
the whole problem with our country in
Western civilization itself if we hadn't
been so nice
we wouldn't be under attack now we're
being sued because we made the mistake
of being kind to immigrants that's what
you're arguing well well no I I think
we've sued because when the government
wants to tear a set of families apart I
know we're talking about American
children school-aged children it has to
have very good reasons they don't think
the government is shown okay if they're
not [ __ ] Connie this is a set of
people who've been no home right I get
it
I'm sure they're nice I just I think
these are fair questions we're out of
time
and healing but thank you for coming on
and explaining that I appreciate it